[Music]
welcome back so we're coding up
different uses of the singular value
decomposition in Python and now we're
ready to talk about how to use the SVD
to compute the principal component
analysis or PCA and PCA again is one of
the most important techniques in the
statistical analysis of high dimensional
data so if you have big data and you
want to understand what are the kind of
dominant directions of variants in that
data then the principal component
analysis is going to be the right tool
for that and we're going to compute it
using the singular value decomposition
so as I always like to say if you're
going to use a mathematical technique in
the real world on a real problem it's a
good idea to check out how it works on a
toy problem where you know the answer
first so that's what we're going to do
here is we are going to essentially
create a data set that is you know
Gaussian distributed data with some
degrees so some directions of high
variance and directions of low variance
and then we're going to demonstrate that
you can use the SVD of that data to pull
out what are those principal and axes of
variance and so on and so forth okay so
so what we're going to do here is in the
stupider notebook we're gonna create a
data set that is a large Gaussian cloud
of points that is going to be moved away
from the origin it's going to be
stretched out in some directions and
compressed in others and then it's going
to be rotated so that it still has this
kind of Gaussian shape but it's not zero
mean and it has kind of directions of
principal principal variation okay so
we're going to move the center of our
data to this X C vector so two by one
this is going to be two-dimensional data
so X is going to be a bunch of either
two vectors column vectors with two
elements a bunch of them or a bunch of
row vectors of two elements depending on
how we stack it we're gonna have 10,000
of these two-dimensional points and what
we're gonna do is we're essentially
going to take an initial an initial
cloud of data this is kind of
representing a big gouge and cloud with
unit variance 0 mean we're going to
stretch it out into an ellipsoid given
by it's going to be stretched out by a
factor of 2 in this direction and
smashed by a factor of 2 in the other
direction so the singular values are 2
and point 5 and then we're gonna rotate
this up by an angle of PI over 3 so
we're gonna we're going to stretch it
out rotate it by PI over 3 and then move
the center to the to one location inside
of the origin and then from that cloud
of data so let's just share the last
arrow so now we're gonna have this kind
of cloud of data that is not at the
origin and then from this cloud of data
we're gonna compute the SVD and we're
going to show that the SVD recovers kind
of these principal axes of maximum
variance and minimum variance it'll also
give confidence intervals that you can
use to quantify how likely is a new data
point that it belonged to this
distribution very very useful okay
so again all of this is just plotting
this is constructing the X matrix just
how I described we're going to stretch
it out rotate it and add the center to
it and then what we're gonna do is
compute the principal components of that
data matrix and so the the principal
component analysis of that data matrix
the first thing we're gonna do is we're
gonna compute the average kind of the
center of the data and we're going to
subtract that Center from all of the
data so we're gonna bring it back to the
origin then we're gonna compute the
singular value decomposition of that
mean Center data and what it's going to
do is it's going to tell us the rotation
the U matrix that rotates into this this
frame and it's going to determine the
Sigma matrix that'll tell how stretched
our distribution is along its prints
Laxus how how much variance in the first
direction how much variance in the
second direction and so on and so forth
so I'm going to plot these and then
we're also going to figure out what the
one standard deviation confidence
interval and two standard deviation and
three standard deviation are based on
that information so let's just run this
and see what it looks like okay great so
this is the original distribution of
data these are they're 10,000 points in
X 1 and X 2 and notice that the center
of the data is not exactly at 0-0 it's a
2-1 okay so it's not mean centered it
has these directions of variants that
are high variance low variance and it
sits at an angle of PI over three so
when you when you Cape take the SVD of
that matrix of data then what you find
is a sigma that essentially has two
elements that are 2 and 0.5 and that
tells you that the first principal
direction has you know a lot of variance
to a variance of 2 and the second
direction has has small variance of
variance of 0.5 okay what it also tells
you the information in this u matrix
this tells you how this distribution is
rotated at what angle are those
principal components so literally the
red lines here the first line is the
first column of U that's the first
principal component and the second the
second line is the second column that's
the second principal component that
tells you the the direction of maximum
variance and then the direction of the
second direction of a variance in this
case of minimal variance ok and what I
think is really fun is that you can then
use these these actually have
statistical meaning because this is a
pca is built on the assumption that your
data is normally or Gaussian distributed
and our data is because we cooked it up
to be that way and so you can
essentially compute these confidence
intervals
X standard deviation where you take you
times Sigma times a circle so I take a
little unit circle and if I multiply
that unit circle by Sigma and then by
you it maps into this kind of unit
standard deviation ellipse and that's
what I'm plotting as this inner blue
ellipse here the the middle blue ellipse
is a two standard deviation ellipse and
the outer blue ellipse is a three
standard deviation ellipse so this
actually gives you beautiful confidence
intervals so if I have a new data point
out here I can say well that's you know
four or five standard deviations outside
of the distribution it's almost
certainly not on the distribution or as
if I get a data point here I can say how
confident I am that it actually came
from its distribution okay so this was
an example that we cooked up where we
knew the answer for for the principal
components but this just shows that you
can use the SVD to to get these kind of
directions of maximal variance from data
alone okay
thank you